in terms of the size of our of our
budget deficit we were the worst in the
country today we're 20th so they're 31
states are worse off than we are hi this
is Matt Welch for reason TV and I'm
joined this morning by the Governor of
Puerto Rico luis Fortuno welcome thank
you man most people don't realize that
there is a governor in the United States
of America who has cut spending by
twenty percent in the last two years so
let's walk through how that happened to
basically start with telling us what did
you run on back in 2008 and what did
your party run on and then what did you
discover once you check under the hood
of state certainly well we we knew we
were going to be facing a serious fiscal
situation but it was three times as bad
as we thought it would be and I had said
that we needed to shrink the size of
government and that I wanted to actually
put back into people's hands the money
that they had earned working every day
and and that was my pledge however when
I came into office we didn't have money
to meet our first railroad we have to
take out a loan it was really bad so our
cuts are deeper than any other part of
the country because of the situation
dire situation that we face actually the
rating agencies were about to throws
into junk status and we had to act by
time to avoid that from happening in the
first two years however we have been
successful in slashing the size of
government by twenty percent and because
of that we have commenced lowering taxes
across the board now tell us about you
had to go to New York to actually talk
with the writing sense well how did that
meeting go sure actually even before
being sworn in I knew that they have
been lowering our rating year after year
and we were at the brink of becoming you
know or being thrown into junk status so
before being sown in December 08 I flew
up to New York met with the radiate uses
acknowledge that we had a problem I
thought it was bad it was much worse but
but at least told them that we had a
plan and we blood six months and we
immediately started working on that
plan and delivering on that plan and
that's why actually our rating has come
up and people are realizing that there
is a way to go sketch out the size of
the problem what was the budget deficit
what was the state of the economy when
you took office and how has that changed
in two years of course our recession
comments two full years before it
started in the rest of the country so
the economy really was at standstill at
best secondly our state budget deficit
was the largest proportionally speaking
in the country actually in worse than
California which worse proportionally
actually forty-four percent of actually
revenues was deficit so it was it was
really bad and and he was impossible to
handle any type of organization like
that much worse a government so we
didn't have a choice it was not like you
know we wanted to do this this way or
that way we knew it was going to be
twenty percent we just did what was
right and unemployment at the time was
more or less closer to seventeen percent
so just imagine you know we had been in
a deepest recession since the 30s the
unemployment was you know double digits
approaching twenty percent and no light
at the end of the tunnel at all and no
money in the bank concretely what were
the first steps that you took to cut the
size of government well the first step
was to cut my own salary by ten percent
you have to you know actually act that
way if you're in public service I feel I
/ five percent the cabinet secretaries
salaries as well and then we turn to
everything else and we / by fifteen
percent old government contracts you
know if you wanted to hunter with
government we're going to slash fifteen
percent off right away and that existing
contract you ripped up well we we went
back to them you know we said you know
what we're even moving to another place
or we / fifteen percent because we
always had escape clauses and contracts
do have a safe process so so we told
that we we know we cannot continue
paying you as if there's you know no
tomorrow and we we eliminated credit
cards from government official vehicles
cell phones my cell phone I pay for it I
I travel with my own
the card and I get reimbursed and that's
the way to do it I feel and and then we
chart we had no choice would turn to
actually an overloaded gourock recei and
and we by voluntary and mandatory
measures we / 17,000 public employee
positions out of a total state sector of
well actually central government was
about 140,000 so and about 12,000 were
mandatory and the balance we're
voluntary we just had another window
voluntary window of early retirement
that we just added another 4,000 to that
and and again the idea is for them to
either retire altogether or we have
provided them with incentives to create
their own their own businesses
entrepreneurship should be part of our
culture and provided them with also
incentives to go back to school if they
wanted to so we really wanted them to
act continue growing as a person now the
sort of liberal progressive idea about
economics that sort of obtains right now
the Paul Krugman ask idea is that if you
cut the size of government in the teeth
of recession you're just going to make a
recession into a depression so this is
an interesting experiment you've cut the
size and the cost of government what has
happened to the economy for Regan well
from seventeen percent unemployment is
down to 14 and a half percent and all
economic indicators are moving in the
right direction actually by slashing
taxes i'm convinced they will move even
quicker in the right direction but the
truth the matter is that after being in
in a recession for five years this
trimester we're seeing positive numbers
in essentially every every single
economic indicator so it's the opposite
now you cut government first and then
taxes second taxes was just last month
from Nam exotic and talk a little bit
because it's interesting about the the
numbers on the tax cuts and then also
the very unique to Puerto Rico system of
triggers in the future for tax of course
ah first of all our our internal revenue
code is a mirror image
the Federal Internal Revenue Code so in
that sense we had the 54 code which is
pretty similar so what we've done and
just interrupt you don't pay federal
taxes we don't pay federal taxes on
Puerto Rico source income if I make
money in any of the 50 states that I pay
federal taxes on that we do pay ficon
Medicare you know all that stuff but we
don't pay income tax so so what we did
in Puerto Rico is doable at the national
level and what we did is we / individual
and corporate taxes across the board on
the corporate side we had a thirty-nine
percent top corporate rate plus a2
percent surtax that was imposed by my
predecessor so it was actually effective
tax rate of forty-one percent we / that
down to thirty percent this year and to
twenty-five percent by 2014 on the evil
side we slash taxes by twenty-five
percent this year and actually it's a
sliding scale in the next five years
that will at the end of the day save
taxpayers an average of forty nine
percent in their taxes what happens
halfway through it however is that we
must balance our budget by 2013 by the
end of 2013 if we haven't balance our
budget and we're not meeting our goals
on the fiscal side then we will not move
into the next phase in 2014 15 and 16 so
that makes a taxpayer they watch dog of
our tax cuts and they watch the watchdog
of responsible government now this would
suggest that you're basically bringing
the taxpayers on board as part of this
project how has the reaction been so far
I imagine that it hasn't been totally
smooth there must be people who squawk
when you cut 17,000 government jobs and
and have a different idea of economics
than then sort of mainstream well
there's there's some that have if it'll
also fee that actually the government
can handle our money much better than we
can I totally disagree I believe that
actually people are working hard
sometimes with two or three jobs to earn
that money they should keep it and and
they they are no much better than any
government how to handle it starting
with my own so I I went on
I've been preaching this message there
is some disbelief out there I'll be
honest with you people don't believe
that actually we're slashing taxes
dramatically as dramatically as we are
because this had never happened before
the last time in Puerto Rico at least
that the government / taxes was almost
20 years ago ever since then the
government has been raising taxes and
taking more and more of our own car
money so this we're moving in the right
direction for the first time in a
generation and so there's some disbelief
actually went on the State of the State
address with the tax return show showing
the boaters which line they will use to
get a credit this first year of the tax
reform because I know a lot of people
simply cannot believe this is happening
there was some pushback when we
commenced doing what we did but then
again you I get elected to do the right
thing not to be popular every single day
and I did the right thing and I'm
convinced that at the end of the day
taxpayers will actually be doing much
better than they were before because of
what we've done and this will be
permanent and that's exactly what I want
to do what are the sources of opposition
who's trying to block you well certainly
the minority in our state legislature
the unions have been trying to block us
as well but at the end of the day
there's nothing more powerful than
individual freedom desire to grow and do
better for yourself and your family and
and that's more powerful than any union
any government any party and I'm
convinced that that's why this will be
permanent you're here in Washington
right now to attend the Conservative
Political Action Conference and you've
been at National Governors Association
type of meetings what message do you
have to the other governors particularly
the new ones who got elected in 2010 who
want to cut size of government and
reduce things what what is replicated
about the Puerto Rican experiment so far
well let me tell you a lot of states are
facing exactly the same situation we
phased two years ago actually we were
dead last
when I started my in office two years
ago in terms of the size of our of our
budget deficit we were the worst in the
country today we're 20th so there are 31
states are worse off than we are and how
is the bond rating rankings change 12
51st basically and exactly and actually
today we have the highest rating in 35
years and for the first time since 1983
the rating agencies have provided us
with a positive outlook for our economy
and our fiscal situation and they're
saying it i'm not saying this you know
it's is the third parties are saying
this what i told the new governor's is
that they must ask act swiftly and and
do everything they need to do year one
communicated properly and level with
people that you know if it's bad tell
people that it's bad and tell them what
you're going to do and start with your
own salary and and if you do that people
will buy it there'll be some pushback
where people will buy it and they'll be
time enough time for you to actually
then lower taxes and do you know and
implement pro-growth policies which is
what we all believe in now you are a
member of the republican party at the
same time you're member of the matter
tell us about that course the old
statehood republican party in puerto
rico back in the 60 guild statehood
republican exactly and that was the
republican party no Rico in the 60s
switch its name into because it's a
local party switch its name into what I
will call a new party for progress and
essentially because we have pro-growth
policies so but we are fiscally
conservative a fiscally conservative
party that wishes to lower taxes and
actually maintained in check the size of
government tell us about statehood now
you're Pro statehood what is the case
for it and where are those politics
right now in Puerto Rico sure well we've
been part of this great country since
1898 actually we have been citizen since
nineteen seventeen and we have certain
every single War alongside are you know
citizens from you know every other state
in this country in every single war in
the 20th century
and a 21st century as well so if we are
good enough to fight alongside other
citizens from every single state in the
country in the trenches we should be
good enough to also partake in the
decision-making process in this country
and I'm convinced that if we were to be
part of that process actually I believe
we have a lot to bring to the table we
are bicultural and bilingual so if we
want to open trade with the rest of the
region I believe we can be extremely
helpful in that as well and and and it
just makes no sense that there are four
million American citizens that cannot
fully participate in the decision-making
process of laws and regulations that
apply to us today you know all laws and
regulations that apply to every single
state applied to Puerto Rico but we
cannot participate in that
decision-making process you so you can
vote you can't vote for president but
you could run for president it's not
well we're yes because we're
natural-born citizens and actually if
you move to Puerto Rico you lose your
right to vote for the president if I
move to DC or Virginia or California I
gain that right because we're citizens
it's a territorial issue not a
citizenship issue what needs to happen
in order for statehood to take place
well it's very simple a request I guess
I know it will be the simplest way of
request by the people of Puerto Rico the
voters in Puerto Rico for that and a
simple majority in the House and the
Senate and the signature by the
president's of an enabling bill that's
it it's a bill what is there any
traction for that in on the mainland
side of the equation well yes yes indeed
and actually there was a bill that was
approved on the house side in Washington
last year the Senate did not act upon it
no so now we're back to square one as to
what are we going to do and I know we're
getting into a presidential race so
there may not be a lot of people wishing
to discuss this but we've been citizens
since nineteen seventeen we're proud of
it our men and women have served with
valor encouraging every single war ever
since then
and it is time for us to participate
fully in that decision-making process at
the national level you mentioned being
bilingual state essentially i'm sure it
puts you in an interesting position when
it comes to questions of immigration
porto rico had immigration to the
mainland in the 50s and i guess in the
70s in places like the northeast and
florida and also your part of the
country and you get a lot of immigrants
from places like Cuba and Haiti talk
about how that perspective makes you
different or the same than sort of
mainstream Republican approaches towards
immigration well certainly I i if you
want to call me something I'm a Reagan
Republican in the sense that I believe
that this country needs to keep growing
and opening trade and opening ourselves
to ideas and I believe we to open
ourselves in an orderly fashion legal
fashion to new people that want to work
hard I want to add to our national
fabric I want to do better for their own
families it has to be an orderly fashion
of course and that's what we have lacked
for the last few years but but I believe
that if we do it correctly we actually
receive other Cubans for example in the
60s and 70s and they added tremendously
to our economy into the fabric of our
society in Puerto Rico and we're proud
of that we are receiving a lot of
Dominicans actually lately if it's done
in an orderly fashion people that want
to work hard should we received with
open arms and and and make sure that
they go through the legal processes so
that they can they can participate in
this country should there be more visas
given to immigrants than there are
currently Canada does it and many other
countries do it around the globe and
actually they do it and they see their
economies grow when they do it in
orderly fashion so there's no reason why
we should not be doing that I yes I
believe we need to attract more people
our population is not growing as fast as
it needs to in order for our economy to
keep growing that has happened in Europe
as well so we need to really sit sit
back and
and decide what are we going to do and
what do we want to do as a country and
then and then provide for a process so I
can happen legally you also sit in any
interesting geographical place and the
Caribbean there's a lot of questions on
various islands there about the effects
of drug policy on on your Island and
transshipment what is your perspective
on our kind of drug laws and and whether
they're the drug war is working well
it's not working it's obvious it it's
not and actually what has happened is
that when the border was closed down in
the southwest a lot of the drug
trafficking then moved shifted towards
the Caribbean area that's where we are
and we have seen an increase in violence
in our region and certainly that is of
grave concern to us and I have been
coming here to Congress actually to talk
about this just this week because either
we need the resources to handle this or
politics after we amended but something
must must give otherwise we continue in
this in this violent way that that is
affecting our society which was not the
case before and all this happened after
the border was closed in the southwest
what do you say policies have to be
amended is there anything in particular
that you personally advocate well in
right now what I want is make sure that
we have the resources to handle this we
are not provided that adequate resources
people forget that we are the third
border shall we say and that that that
our area has to be treated as the
northern and southern border and because
the moment you're in Puerto Rico you're
in Iowa because they're really there is
no immigration papers or anything that
you have to fill up it's like moving you
know driving from or flying actually
from LA to New York exactly the same
thing I believe that actually those that
and we're doing what I'm going to tell
you those that are have an addiction
must be treated not as criminals but
they should be treated as people that
actually have an addiction and you can
have an addition to anything
and then they should be treated
accordingly and we are providing medical
processes to to treat people that have
an addiction talk briefly about some of
the things that you're doing in terms of
public-private partnerships and and
getting private sector money to do
things even like help build or refurbish
schools well it is obvious that our
governments no longer have the kind of
money we used to have to develop our
basic infrastructure so what we've done
is that we went around the world
actually and we looked at the Canadian
model the australian model european
model and and then we we draft our own
that be through your public private
partnership legislation that is
extremely effective and and actually now
it is attracting a lot of capital from
all over the world to construct and
maintain schools roads and highways
airports water projects energy projects
and actually the interest that we have
attracted is is unbelievable I believe
that instead of having a project for one
highway in one state States should move
towards having p3 programs so that all
of our infrastructure can be upgraded
with private capital and that it's done
in a regular basis in many other
countries for some reason in the state's
that's not being done with very few
exceptions I believe we can be the
showcase of be three projects for the
rest of America given what we've seen
and what we will be seen in 2011 what
where are you in that process sure we
have already commenced a modernization
process of our schools and we have the
first phase one is a hundred schools we
actually already contracted out about 30
35 of them we should be finished by the
end of the summer in the second quarter
of this year we will actually have a
contract that out to highways and we're
hoping that by the second half of this
year will be able to contract our main
airport so that all will have happen in
2011 talk a little bit about your
personal philosophy where did you get
these crazy ideas
about how to run government and how best
to to have economic calls well I was in
school here in DC back in the late 70s
early 80s and I lived through the end of
carter and reagan it was really
President Reagan who brought me into the
party and and then I started reading a
lot about it and and following what was
going on and I saw how tough it was at
the beginning of President Reagan's term
to actually clamp down a runaway
government but at the end of the day we
then experienced the longest growth we
have ever experienced in you know except
for for period of wars so so we it
worked and it worked extremely well back
in the 80s even though he didn't
actually cut government on that well
there was a arms race going on and
states thank goodness don't happen here
to worry about that so so that there was
another aspect that actually affected
that policy but if if you take away the
arms race he indeed was able to slash
the size of government so so I I felt
that if you apply it at the state level
it should work and that's exactly what
we've done and what have you been doing
in your career to first term governor
what what are we doing well for four
years I represent the Puerto Rico in the
US Congress and before that I was just
racing my kids and practicing law and
enjoying myself what you're in the
middle of CPAC here is mentioned before
there's a lot of foofaraw over whether
CPAC is becoming too tolerant towards a
gay Republican groups where do you stand
on social issues or where the Republican
Party is right now with some of these
divides when I tell you I believe in the
free flow of ideas I don't think the
government or anybody else should try to
stop that that's why we we are the
freest and greatest nation in the world
and and to try to stop that you know you
may disagree with some some of the
groups are maybe there that's great
should be exposed to them our ideas and
then you should decide whether you
disagree or agree with them but I don't
believe in shutting off different groups
in the country do you have any ambitions
to get involved in national mainland
politics well I want to see I want to
assist the Hispanic community in many
ways and I would love to see the
Republican Party embraced a Hispanic
community even more so than that it does
today so to the extent that I can assist
in that I would love to be helpful in
that area tell us what you're doing now
with the school system I believe in
choice on the one hand and I really
parents have a better understanding of
what's best for their kids than any
government by the same token I believe
that we have a values crisis in our
nation and that affects Puerto Rico as
well so we have taken off what's called
character counts and you may have heard
about it you know many other counties
and cities and states they have done
this at the local level we are the first
state or territory to do this at the
statement and we are we have started a
process by which we want to cover all
public schools with the character counts
program we have started with a 205
schools 72,000 students but the idea is
to take this to every single public
school what does it mean in fact what it
means is that the curriculum is adjusted
to actually underscore basic universally
accepted values like honesty that
responsibility hard work stability I
mean I'm not we're not trying to impose
values on anyone these are universally
accepted value and actually before we
even started this we we checked and we
asked among students and parents and and
opinion leaders in Puerto Rico what how
did they feel about this values and you
know it was nine to one approval so so
we said okay we're on the right track
and then so we are adjusting our
curriculum so that we indeed underscore
and strengthen those values so our kids
at the end of the day are better
citizens and you mentioned something
about school choice what if anything are
you doing in that motion to free up
parental choice as well as in Puerto
Rico we had try that before and we had
some legal issues we are at this moment
looking at what has been done in Florida
and other states to implement it in
Puerto Rico we again we want parents to
have a greater say in what happens with
their kids right now if I'm parent of a
child in Puerto Rico can I say I don't
like the school that I'm next to I want
to go to that school you could do it yes
you could do that but we want to even
free up that process even more and and
of course what I call the permanent
government tries to stop you from doing
that so we want to make sure that we
empower parents even further and that's
the process worryin looking at the
national scene what other politicians
governor's people out there do you see
as either a role model or a colleague
someone that you think is pointing in
the right direction for just public
policy in general well I believe mitch
Daniels has done a excellent job in
Indiana actually he actually tried the
p3 program with one or two highways as I
understand it I like st. the same way
I've tim Pawlenty didn't feel a few
things they were interesting and
handling size of government in Minnesota
and I enjoyed you know really sitting
down with him and sharing he shared some
of these ideas with me as well and I so
I like that as well I just spoke with a
new governor rick scott from florida and
they are doing what we have already done
in terms of medicaid use of Medicaid
funds and trying to move
into a greater flexibility for for
beneficiaries and and so I believe a lot
of things are happening all over the
country and I'm excited about that it's
happening at the state level that's
great thank you very much for being with
us thank you and best of luck for recent
TV I am Matt Welch